good morning and welcome to the press
conference for the e8th Berlin science
week this event means that uh the
science week is just around the corner
and today we would like to take the
opportunity to tell us a bit uh tell you
a bit more about the program and the
highlights first of all we would like to
extend a big thank you to our host today
which is hmar 25 the cultural center and
our new partner and a little bit more
about this will come in a second so I
would like to start with uh introducing
our panelists um I will start with Ena
chipa senator for Higher Education and
Research health and long-term care
uh y mun coordinator Berlin science week
and chairman of the falling balls
Foundation Lisa bankson ahead of Berlin
science week P Georgio aloto science
scientific atese of the Italian um
Embassy in Berlin Martin Renard who is
the chairman of the Einstein Foundation
Berlin and Roman Angel Herber director
of Paul drud Institute for solid state
Electronics uh just a couple of words
about uh the agenda today so we will
we'll start with the panelist speeches
in a second we'll also like to say hello
and welcome to everybody who is joining
us via the live stream if you have any
questions you can uh leave them in the
chat and uh my colleagues will also pass
them to us uh we will have a brief Q&A
section in the end of the press
conference and without any further Ado I
will pass the word to the senator
please thank you very much Berlin
science week is a celebration of the
intellectual exchange among scientists
with hundreds of participants from all
over the world this 10day Festival aims
to make exciting research work
accessible to all to all those
interested as an international Hub of
innovation and a meeting place for a
Cosmopolitan community of scientists
Berlin is an ideal location to host this
event but what is it that makes this
city so unitedly appealing to
researchers more than 100 100 years ago
the art critic Carl schfer wrote about
this rather ambivalent relationship with
berin in a quote that still aptly
describes the city he said about the
German capital in 1910 Berlin is
condemned to perpetually become and
never to be this continuous state of
creation and transformation is what
makes billons so attractive both for
people working in creative and
scientific Fields not only is this the
key to the vibrancy of the city but it
is also a Hallmark of outstanding
science research is never truly finished
science must deal with dead ends
numerous dors surprising shortcuts when
the destination is finally inside it
quite often is different than initially
expected finding answers to scientific
questions always brings forth a new set
of questions which is turn want to be
answered thus science is itself in a
Perpetual process and becoming but there
are also very practical reasons for an
international appeal of Bin science four
universities six universities of applied
science three art colleges private
universities and numerous research
institutions Mark berin is one of the
most prominent locations of Science in
Europe the high concentration of
research facilities in the city promotes
the exchange of their findings and an
ongoing cooperation between them making
berin very attractive for scientists
worldwide the Berlin University Alliance
is built on this close collaboration of
Berlin's universities and looks to even
further strength strengthen it by
creating an integrated research space
which also includes many non-university
research facilities such as the max
plank Li Nets or helmholz
Institute the full range of Cutting Edge
research in Berlin was also evident in
the great success of Berlin's
institutions in the funding line for
clusters of excellence in the DF gay
Excellence strategy with seven clusters
being approved in Berlin No Other German
location was able to attract more from
artificial intelligence to new materials
and Global challenges for the for the
model of liberal democracy and market
economy to comprehensive approaches on
Urological and psych psychiatric
disorders the range of topics that the
part participating scientists are
researching is
Broad the Berlin science week aims to
bring this diverse research closer to
the people in Berlin who benefit in many
ways from the excellent work of the
numerous scientific institutions right
at their doorstep after all the many
Social Challenges of our time cannot be
met without science science has a
mandate to provide answers in the many
societal questions be it in the field of
ecology and climate change
digitalization artificial intelligence
or health care I'm sure that the
scientists involved will also find new
inspiration of their work through the
exchange with the particip ipants and
fellow researchers therefore the Senate
department for Higher Education and
Research health and long-term care is
very happy to support the Berlin science
week this year and in the future to
fulfill its important Mission I would
like to express my sincere thanks to the
numerous organizers and participating
scientists for making this exciting
exchange possible the effort required to
hold such an huge event is considerable
but it I'm sure it has really been worth
it thank
you thank you so much Ina chib senator
for Higher Education and Research health
and longterm care of Berlin and now the
next word uh is passed on to Y Lun
coordinator Berlin science B chairman of
falling walls Foundation please thank
you hello good morning to uh
everybody I'm very glad that you know we
only have uh what four more weeks to go
before this year's berin science week
and uh also the following World science
summit starts let me uh first say a few
words of thanks because you know at the
end time is running and you always
forget to thank those who made all this
possible so uh Senator chora thank you
very much for the support of the city of
Berlin uh without that support the ber
learn science week could not take place
thank you very much um that's
wonderful um we have a great team um
that uh you know takes care of
everything I come back to also some
numbers in a moment and then uh olena
thank you very much for having organized
this press conference and thank you of
course for being here hopefully asking
questions later on and I also say hello
to our digital audience
we also have uh you know this uh bil
lager as we say in
English of the
tarer which is just great I hope someone
from the tarer is here wonderful thank
you very much I browse through it uh I
mean it's in the newspapers this morning
I think it's great I come back to it in
a moment
now we live in difficult times I come
back to that too
um a couple of years ago we had the
pandemic and we couldn't meet you know
person by person now last year for the
first time again this was possible it's
possible again this year and this is
just wonderful because science lives
also from personal
context I just was on a similar
conference as falling wordss in
Japan uh a couple of days ago the SD
forum and you know talking also to the
colleagues in the Asian Pacific area
gives you a
complete different feeling on what is
happening in different part of the world
than just looking at your screen you
really have to talk to the people you
have to meet them and you have to make
personal uh contexts and that's I think
one of the key issues of the bin science
week and also of uh of the falling W
sign andit as a matter of fact I uh have
some numbers here
9% this year are
digital pure in a certain sense 15%
hybrid which means most of the over 150
events will be person by person and this
is great I think Berlin again after the
pandemic with scientist and you know
people that are interested in science
research and Innovation from all over
the
world what are the challenges of the
future besides you know all these
geostrategic and
political um events that really
preoccupy uh us nearly daily now it's uh
the climate issue it's the energy
transformation it's all also
demography and all these topics will be
covered during the berin science week so
it's on science but it's also on
humanities and social science it's on
architecture it's on economy we really
cover during the Berlin science week the
full spectrum with all our partners and
I'm very very um thankful also and
grateful to our colleagues being here on
stage I mean they are just a few
examples of those to participate with a
lot of creative ideas I think you will
come back also to I mean this Art and
Science uh Forum which we can organize
due to the support of of the city of
Berlin which is some kind of new aspect
also of the berin science we bringing
science and art together which is also
important because both is part of our
culture and of our values and I
think this value aspect is also is also
really at at the heart of what we are
doing in in science research and
Innovation
anyhow what are some um
highlights
um I could go through this little
document in detail but I won't do it I
just want to give a few
examples and uh let me
see if if you go through the starish
Beagle bya you see I mean nearly daily
there are there are activities for
example November 3 to5 labor and
IM immobility and mobility in Japan and
East and Southeast Asia transnational
Regional and rural urban
perspectives that's by
this has some context to what I said at
the beginning but listen next year and
the senator knows it there will be the
30th anniversary of the partnership
between the city of Berlin and the City
of Tokyo and I think we should celebrate
this also next year in the context of
the Berlin science week and the falling
WS event just one
example um we have a again the
Campos um at the museum for n cond the
Museum of national history and again you
see from November 2 to November what is
it 4 we have a number of events at one
side this is also you know part of the
concept of the berin science week having
something distributed all over the city
but also some kind of your you know spot
where you can go and where you are sure
that you will meet people and uh where
there will be different um
activities finally and then I end uh let
me say a few
words also on uh the falling wordss
conference which at the end you know is
I think one of the uh highlights
November 7
to9 and I come back to what I said you
know uh at the very beginning last year
we had the Russian aggression against
Ukraine and those who were with us last
year remember you know this picture this
is also on the front cover of our annual
report uh stand with
Ukraine but you know November 9 is not
only the day of the fall of the wall in
Berlin it's also for the Germans to
remember the so-called rice
progam and this you know has a
special this has a special
accent this year in view of what just
happened in in Israel and be sure we
will cover this aspect this year too at
the falling Wards
conference uh we cover a broad spectrum
uh of uh topics just as an example on
November 9 we will have something on the
threedimensional
um picture of our Milky Way this will be
the starting presid presentation by
Amina
heli later on we hear something about
the latest development in earthquake
research we wanted to cover this also
this year in view of the earthquakes
that happened uh we will have something
from South Africa on female uh fear um
intersections of gender and and fear in
the public
space we hear news about about this
laser driven Fusion from the Lawrence
Livermore lab in uh California that made
a splash in view of breakthrough in
laser
Fusion we will hear about uh this
adipositas drug from Matias chup which
will help to fight a
depositors we have someone from Google
to talk about uh recent developments in
AI of course a I will be one of the you
know topics that will will be covered
broadly CH GPT but AI in a more General
sense we have uh anupa kundo to talk
about sustainable architecture and Uria
mandia from Berkeley who will talk about
uh economic issues related to inflation
so a very broad spectrum and we are
looking forward to all these science
events which are public which are in
English which are in German which are By
Invitation Only which are long which are
short and I think we cover all what you
know you might want to hear during a
couple of days about science research
and Innovation at the global level so
that's
it thank you so much y m coordinator of
Brin science week and chairman of the
falling walls foundation for given an
overview of one of the first highlights
that we mentioned just now falling wall
s Summit that will take place between
the 7th and 9th of November and then the
word goes to the head of Berlin science
feic Lisa bankson who will tell us a bit
more about the news coming up this year
and also a bit more about the program in
general please Louisa yes hello uh I am
super excited a bit nervous this is my
first uh building science week so uh in
this function so I'm really looking
forward to it and I hope everything goes
according to plan you can imagine
there's a lot of work in the background
uh but we are doing it and the wonderful
team that's almost all of them are here
it's also new most of them um and
without this wonderful really engaged
team and I would love to talk about each
one of them in detail but of course I
don't have time to it but really thank
you very much I mean I'm so blessed in a
way to say it in American way so um yeah
okay but now to the building science
week what's new um a lot actually does
building science week will be different
than the other ones the same great Bing
science week as ever but new in many
different ways so first new thing uh we
have now several physical locations when
we concentrate the program so that's
just our traditional campus in the
Museum of Natural History which uh
you're already mentioned that's
happening on the November 3rd and 4th
that's going to be amazing please come
all there uh we have all kinds of topics
that I will talk about in a second but
the second location and that's why we
here is the HZ Mark 25 this is here the
whole area thanks to our partners here
we are able and thanks to the to the
Senate the additional funding from the
Senate we're able to conduct this Arts
and Science forum for the first time
creative science precise art is the
motto for the Arts and Science Forum
happening here and you can expect uh
well actually quite mindblowing
experiences everything from Tiny
galleries to multisensory performers
experiences but also workshops and talks
and comedy um really pretty much
everything is going to be happening here
and we're also going to be ending with
the bank so we're going to have for the
first time ever a uh bing science week
concluding party um a science club night
so it's not just any party it's going to
be science party so we're going to be
talking about the science of Rave in
theory but also then practice so uh
that's the that's the preview and also
there's um someone here is going to
present one of the highlights uh at The
Forum in a moment um so that's about the
Arts and Science Forum we are also now
for the first time ever going to Poland
so we have program on the culture train
cutu which goes between Berlin and frav
um every weekend actually since many
years uh and hopefully continue to do so
for many years so we have a program on
the train because this train is an event
train and uh we will also work with
Polish uh scientists to also deliver
program here in Berlin from Poland so
that's uh that's not a new aspect which
brings me also to the overall uh more
International internationality of
building science week so building
science week is really as um both F and
Y mentioned is about building bridges
and about getting people to talk to each
other and this is more important than
ever in our world and it's not only more
important and U you know because it's
our gut feeling that it is important
it's really research has shown that uh
really to get people to really
understand each other and work together
you really get have to get them in the
same space and talk to each other so
this is exactly what building science is
doing and I think we have to go beyond
just uh you know just our regional reach
so uh we have a lot of international
guests at the building science week we
have over 500 speakers and many many of
them I don't have exact numbers but
really at least every almost every event
has an international speaker involved um
we have contributions from almost 20
countries from around the globe so from
several countries in Africa uh from
India from Japan from Italy uh we'll
talk about it in a moment uh from us
from Mongolia I mean really from pretty
much really everywhere and notably also
from Ukraine and from Israel so we are
really looking forward to this um
program items
okay um and the topics okay maybe the
topics the topics are also important
right so um we have a lot of physics
this year which is I think capturing
pretty well that side Guist uh so if
you're looking at the look at the Nobel
prizes this year it's a lot of uh well
quantum physics and photonics and we
have all that at the building science
week so that's uh there's a lot of
physics and also from different uh takes
so it's not just talks about you know
theoretic physics it's really making
physics accessible and experienceable
for all so that's happening we have a
lot of uh talk about working in Academia
working conditions in Academia so uh we
will be we will be exploring how how
does Academia look like now and how
should it be in order to be actually
continuing to contribute to the you know
to to the good of all um so there's a
lot of that we have topics from
architecture be talking about the future
of democracy and the future of economy
uh we'll be also talking about gender
inequality in different aspects a lot of
AI of course uh but not only uh in let's
say Health Sciences but also for example
in Music Creation so creativity and I
very important topic also for the
creative
industry I cannot list all the topics
here and I can just tell you that each
one of the program items is a highlight
it's really all of them extremely
interesting and truly Innovative and
really uh worthwhile visiting and um as
you're already mentioned there is this
whole full program is in this magazine
and it's also online and because there
are so many it's 200 events happening at
the buing science week and there are so
many of them we'll be create uh we'll be
creating topic tracks and this will be
on the website shortly where we can
group The the topics and help you
navigate the
program one special event I would like
to mention uh that's going to be
happening at the buing science week so
uh in order to explore this idea of
talking to each other meeting each other
in person and really um forging peace
through cooporate scientific cooporation
we have two actually two events at the
believe science week one is um at the
Natural History Museum in the campus on
the 4th of November uh where we have a a
panel discussion on on science diplomacy
we'll be exploring this topic in more
detail and the second one which uh we
are very proud of and really um happy
that we we able to do this uh here at
Holz Mark 25 on the 5th of November we
will have a live painting of a buddy
bear so buddy Bears you know this Bine
symbol of Tolerance and peace um so
together with the body bear um company
uh body Bear game be um b b BD bear
berene it's called officially sorry um
so to get together uh we are organizing
life painting event here and uh we have
asked several embassies in Berlin to
contribute to to this action it's it's
going to be an action it's going to be
live here and um the Ukrainian Embassy
is the recipient of this Badd bear so um
several International um scientists
hopefully uh will contribute to this
body bear and this will be then standing
in front of the Ukraine Embassy um in
the future so that's um I think
that's it for me for no yeah and I'm
very happy to ask any uh to answer any
specific questions you might have thank
you so much Louisa thank you so Louisa
already mentioned the news for this year
Art and Science Forum in HZ Mark 25 from
the 1st to the 10th of November uh where
we will focus on the Synergy of Arts and
Science yeah so a little bit more about
that also to to follow soon and now the
next speaker is pi Georgio aloto
scientific atese of Embassy of Italy in
Berlin please thank you thank you so
much um well I'm also very excited
because it's not only my first presence
here at the berin SS week but also my
first press conference so two reasons
for being excited um having said that um
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to to be here today and I'm the fourth
in the row so things get easier and
easier the the more you go on because so
much has been said so I will try not to
repeat myself too much with things you
have already heard but anyhow I would
like to stress before I I really tell
you what we do in the context of the
Berlin science week what I think is is
important for an embassy so Embassy have
the mission of promoting cooperation
collaboration and understanding so
really finding the opportunity of being
present at the Berlin science week is
really fits very well within the mission
of what we do and actually actually as I
will tell you we are also very happy
that we can open up the embassy to the
general public because embassies should
not be Ivory Towers that are close to
the public but they should also be a
place where the public can enter and and
experience things so we are very glad
that one of the two events we are
organizing will be inside our Embassy
the other one will be at the campus so
two very good opportunities for us to uh
share with the public two uh aspects of
international cooperation
research and as was said um a lot of
physics the things we do are physics and
Engineering I would say uh two very
different things which I'll I'll be
talking about and as was mentioned there
are problems that really need an
international effort to be solved we've
learned it in uh in the occasion of the
pandemic we have learned it when the
unfortunate War events uh took place all
of a sudden the energy uh Spectrum
changed everybody was very scared of not
having access to energy so we see that
uh problems very very quickly spread
across borders and must be faced at the
global level not at the level of the
single
country problems don't look at physical
boundaries they don't look at Geographic
boundaries they just spread and the
solution to to these problems must be
tackled on a global scale so I'm very
happy um I'm I'm I can't say a scientist
I'm an engineer by trade but I'm anyway
I'm not not a diplomat good enough
that's good enough the second best
approximation to being a
scientist and so I I consider myself
very very fortunate because science uh
has the ability of looking over some
problems even when there was a strong
division between the East and the West
the scientists were Cor operating and
this is a very important lesson that
scientists find a way of cooperating
even in the most dramatic
circumstances so this I think is fits
very well within the the context of the
falling walls
Mission having said that uh the two
things we are we are uh presenting this
year are two examples of such
International fruitful scientific
corporation which allows to uh invest
the limited resources that mankind has
to devote to science in a very efficient
way so cooperation is a key to
efficiently invest the money that that
we have to do research the first thing
uh we will be presenting will be at the
Museum on um on October the 3 it's an
event on nuclear fusion for
decarbonization we all know humankind
needs energy energy is needed not only
to know know for the light pulps but
energy is needed for everything also to
produce clean water for example so
energy is really a key enabling thing
that Humanity needs we all know that the
production of energy has very strong
impacts on climate the uh solution of
climatic challenges is certainly a very
very urgent problem for mankind nuclear
fusion looks at being a long-term
solution to this challenge nuclear
fusion is the mechanism that powers the
stars
now nature sometimes loves simplicity so
it invented a way of producing energy
with a very very simple reaction uh
unfortunately in Stars this re reaction
is easy because they are so huge and
there is a lot of you know heat and and
pressure that allows this thing to
happen on Earth it's much much more
challenging so right now I think the
um the physics is more or less well
understood but the engineering is still
a major hurdle so we are bringing
together some of the leading uh experts
in science not the um uh laser
confinement that was mentioned but
magnetic confinement we will bring
together experts from Italy from Germany
from Japan from the United States and
for ether which is the largest uh
worldwide project on magnetic
confinement Fusion together to U
democratize this uh this very
interesting and Val very challenging
topic as I said at the Museum open to to
the public there won't be apart from
maybe a few invited guests all the seats
will be reserved to the public to
explore um to explore this topic it will
be about 50 minutes of presentation and
then a lot of time for discussion and
and for questions by the public which we
find very important so uh the the
scientist should not just teach as it
was a university lecture but they should
interact with the public and explain why
such things although uh expensive and
complicated really need to be addressed
through International
cooperation the second topic again is
physics but a totally different thing so
Fusion is for an immediate problem that
mankind has to solve which is producing
clean energy the other topic we will be
presenting is uh gravitational waves so
a very fundamental thing gravitational
waves is uh a known phenomenon it has
been awarded a Nobel Prize in 2017 so it
is a known
fact um but we want to push it further
and um and to push it further we need
very very large telescopes now it's not
a telescope as you would imagine
something that captures light tiny tiny
signals of light coming from very uh
distant galaxies but uh this telescope
will need to detect faint signals in the
Distortion of as they say SpaceTime okay
big sounding word but actually they will
um deflect laser beams okay that's
that's uh that's what it boils down to
the physicist will excuse
me um okay um
anyhow but to do to to build such a
thing you need uh a very very quiet
environment and not quiet in the sense
of music and Raves but in the sense of
geological stability so your mirrors
should not vibrate and there aren't that
many places in the world where you can
host such a huge facility so you need a
uh holes or tunnels that extend for tens
of kilometers to be able to detect such
faint signals and there aren't many
places as I said on Earth where you can
do such experiments fortunately or
unfortunately for Europe in Europe there
are at least two such places to build
such a huge telescope and to build it we
need a very very broad International
cooperation which certainly uh will
include Germany it will include Italy it
will include the Netherlands and many
other uh contribut Poland Spain many
many scientists will have to work
together we are talking about probably
somewhere in the neighborhood of 10,000
scientists working on the same site so
it's a huge collaboration project that
is uh going to be called Einstein
telescope Einstein did a lot of work on
gravity and not only you know on on
light and and so um the target of this
event is to popularize this uh
gravitational wave research Mak it
accessible much better than than I did
right now and also to present uh the um
proposal that Italy has to do for
hosting the telescope physically in
Sardinia um so concluding words we would
like the public who will be attending
these events to walk away not only with
a little more bit more knowledge on
specific topics but above all to get a
feeling for how much scientific
cooperation across boundaries is
relevant and I think this is I guess
what what the falling walls Foundation
wants to to have to promote as a message
so we are very very glad to have this
opportunity and thank you very
much thank you very much P joio aloto
scientific ate of Embassy of Italy in
Berlin the embassy we're very happy to
have the embassy uh again on the program
and the embassy is presenting two
science Week events uh in November and
moving forward Martin Rena chairman
Einstein Foundation
Berlin thank you very
much physics were just mention mentioned
that he looked at me I'm not a
physicist I think he is I am he
is um but Einstein also was mentioned as
a chairperson of the Einstein Foundation
here in Berlin a state funded Foundation
here in Berlin to promote excellence in
science and in research in this
town and as a part of a very vibrant
week coming up 10 days actually I
believe um I think it is very important
as has been said before before I go into
what we are doing to reflect on some
things which were already said the first
of of them is of course the situation uh
in the world and I'm not only speaking
about Israel I'm speaking of the Ukraine
I'm speaking about the problems which
arise from not being able to cooperate
you have just made a very good case for
the necessity of
cooporation we have and jck did that the
same just before uh concerning the
Oceania Japan other places it was
mentioned that East and West used used
to in a certain sense uh be in contact
on the scientific level all over these
many decades as a matter of fact this
time in which we live now has its uh
unique challenges the geopolitical
situation has changed in a way which
makes me personally and many of our
colleagues one wonder whether this kind
of cooperation in a time in which we
need this cooperation more than ever
before as a matter of fact climate
change is just one Global challenge
which we face um whether we can continue
whether we will continue looking at what
is happening between China and the
United
States now um I don't want to go into
this too long because we don't have the
time but the fact is that in the falling
walls conference and in the science week
we will be dealing with a necessity not
only of cooperation but the
absolutely un u it's unambiguous we have
to go that way because if we don't
Humanity will face challenges which we
cannot maybe
Master uh looking at that um looking at
Einstein also who was a physicist as I
said before and as also a person who is
concerned with keeping peace in the
world um we are deeply deeply concerned
about our colleagues not only in Ukraine
also in Israel of course not only the
colleagues but the person everybody
concerning U who's in that situation at
this
moment we have been uh cooperating
because I was speaking about cooperation
of as Einstein the name goes back to a
person who also founded a university in
Jerusalem we have been cooperating our
partners jerus Jerusalem Hebrew
University and we have to extend our
deep regret on what is happen happening
there as we have done last year and this
year again uh the colleagues in Kiev and
other places in the
Ukraine I'll go into that just a bit
more just in order to go into the topic
because the first thing I want to
mention we have a lot of uh events
coming up as you said as I heard 200 I
didn't count them actually is um of a
very interesting has a interesting title
does diversity help or hinder
research the impact on D of diversity on
Research
quality is the name of a of one of our
events in the Natural History Museum by
the way which was also mentioned before
um and that explores something which we
know from other themes and other topics
actually we know that biodiversity is
eminently important for our further
existence but doesn't that the same
doesn't the same thing apply to the re
research ecosystem
don't we need all kinds of people from
all different places in this world in
order to further knowledge and further
the possibility of research and the
capability of our minds that is
something which will go into and I think
that is a very important thing it's also
hybrid by the way hybrid and and present
you can come to the National History
Museum but you also can take part if you
don't um manage to come there but I
think that is one of the big question
questions which we face and I think that
we all face the similar questions in
many other uh topics concerning not
Natural History or the science Natural
Sciences but also in other in other
questions like culture of
course another thing I want to mention
in order not to make this too
long is um something which also concerns
all of us the question of research
quality um for three years now for the
third time now actually we the Einstein
Foundation Berlin has been uh together
with a dump Shong and with the state of
Berlin and with nature and plaws and
many other partners which we are
profoundly thankful for um and the max
plank institutes by the way also we have
been bestowing a prize for research
quality the name is chin Einstein
Einstein Foundation Award for promoting
quality in research and that goes in
three categories the first is a personal
the second is an Institutional but
there's a third one bestowing 100,000
EUR by the way which is quite a lot of
money for early
researchers and during these uh science
week there will be um the choice of the
uh prize winning uh team this year and
that choice will happen on uh November
9th um it is something which you can
take uh in because it is a virtual thing
and it will be via live stream you can
go in into that and you can look at if
160 participants actually um applied
only five I believe five have been or
six actually have been chosen to
participate in that event I think it
would be fascinating we have career
early career teams from all over the
world which is another thing which I'm
very proud of um the third thing I want
to mention is is something totally
different but that also is fascinating I
believe that is Einstein in the dome we
have have been cooperating with the
planetarium for a long time now actually
years and on November 1st um so you have
to U go into the program and you'll find
it there Einstein in the dome in the SI
planetarium in Berlin um will go into
noo technology uh with Professor suu
sudik Su who is an Einstein Professor
for clinical neot technology at the
sh um you will be able to see in a 3D uh
situation I've seen it actually I think
it's absolutely fascinating uh a travel
you travel into the brain and the the
title of the event will be who is
controlling whom it is a journey to the
interface of brain artificial
intelligence and
Robotics um it is a one-hour event uh I
think 6:30 p.m. it says here so in other
words uh it is 6:30 p.m. um I think it
really makes sense to go there um and
you will find something which you cannot
find any other place because of course
you know that projecting in a
planetarium I don't know how many of you
have gone into the planetariums in the
last couple of years it's 36 projectors
as I believe and the whole room is
filled with things which you can travel
into now I um will finish here but I
will repeat once more that I believe in
this vibrant City this vibrant event we
are very proud to participate we are
thankful to all our partners and and we
have a lot of very good partners here um
as we have seen and I'm very excited to
be part of this but we all are part of a
global community and This Global
Community has to stand together in order
to see that science as far as that is
possible together with other things with
politic politicians with culture with
many other things that we managed to
help the world go into a better way than
it is in the
present thank you very much Martin
Renard chairman Einstein Foundation
Berlin and our last speaker is Roman
anger tat director Puda Institute forid
solid state Electronics please thank you
very much and thank you for the
opportunity uh to represent uh the PA
drud Institute here as one of the
participants of the Berlin science week
Paul drud Institute is in the center of
Berlin it's a liess Institute and it's
also part of the for for bu bin and just
from this you can see um how important
science is uh to Berlin as one of the
metropolitan areas and vibrant cities um
where we are doing research and um we
are not only doing research but we also
doing a lot of Outreach sometimes we
open the doors to our institutes the
Berlin science week for us is uh
particularly important uh because it
allows us uh to embark on an action with
the public and with the society and what
PDI has done over the years uh over and
over again within this framework of the
Berlin science week is uh to reach the
unreachable the audience that typically
doesn't come when we have open doors um
and then try to enact with them one of
the ways we're doing this we're actually
located at the Jarman Market in in
Berlin is that since you can't look
through the walls um we allow you to
have a look at what we're doing in the
lab by projecting on our facade what it
is that we actually doing in order to do
science um we also reaching out to folks
for example in subways uh where you are
more focused on minding the Gap when you
are exiting the subway uh we believe
that you should also mind the labs so we
had um an exhibit where you know while
you're switching from Subway to Subway
you could actually also have a look at
what it is that folks scientists
engineers um do in their lab and so this
year uh uh we are very um excited about
the opportunity that uh uh we have with
the Berlin science week to make um
science relatable uh without hiding the
complexity that it has and you know the
the Paul druda Institute is working at
the Nexus of physics so I'm a physicist
by training but we're also working in
the synthesis of materials we do
Material
Science um and we're also doing devices
so we do a whole lot of things we're not
just physicists we are uh much more than
that um and so what we want to do this
year is we want to talk about phase
transitions um um phase transitions like
physicists see this but we want to go
much more Beyond this because we believe
that if I say phase transitions
everybody in the audience thinks about a
particular thing you know if you're
physicist you're thinking about the
state of matter um but if you do
psychology or if you do uh social
sciences you might think about very
different types of transitions of States
um and so um this is one of the things
that we are trying to do trying to bring
this complimenting expertise together in
one room um pushing ourselves um outside
our comfort zone this is what scientists
are trained to do otherwise we can't
gain new knowledge um and we want to
invite everyone to be part of this uh
and talk about uh what phase transitions
really are in particular because uh many
of uh the speakers before were talking
about this uh phas transition in science
uh pH transition in uh in in the society
we might be already just experiencing
one we're coming from a fairly uh stable
State uh the world order seems to change
it's a lot about order and disorder
disorder happens when you have phase
transitions you go from one ordered
state to another ordered State physicist
look at this very different than uh
folks in social sciences so this is one
of these events where we can we can
bring all of these complimenting
perspectives and expertise together um
and it's very exciting to say that the
this is going to happen November 9th uh
this is where we had transitions
particularly in Germany uh going one one
political order to another political
order and we're very excited to welcome
everyone and to have a discussion with
us about
this thank you very much um so we are
through with the presentations and then
I'm just going to ask in the audience if
we have any
questions I also don't think we have any
questions online all right so yeah I
will take that as a compliment uh that
we were really comprehensive with our
presentations and uh just a quick thank
you to our panelists for being here for
sharing the highlights with us for um
hyping us up for the New Berlin science
week that is coming a couple of weeks
and yeah visit our web page uh Berlin
science week.com check out our program
come visit us at the campus and museum
for natural history on the 3D and the
fourth of November visit us at the new
spot that we are celebrating this year
it's the Art and Science Forum at hmark
HSM 25 and see you in November thank
[Applause]
you